wondering why other people's success or  wondering why other people are  successful is the refuge of losers yes  it's a loser mentality it's a loser  occupation it's a it's a it's a loser  practice because you're wondering why  other people are successful  like who gives a [ __ ] you can say you  think it sucks but to spend time  wondering why someone is successful and  hating on someone being successful it  doesn't do any good it's like what is  that old expression that jealousy is  it's a poison that does the opposite of  it's intended  it doesn't affect the other person at  all but it poisons yourself yeah it  wastes your energy and time it just is  so  it's so indicative that you  are insecure yes